Is alien life really out there.
Humanity has wondered about it for decades.
And according to scientists,
it might finally be a reality.
Astronomers have discovered there could be life on Venus.
Does this mean we finally meet aliens?
Could this help us discover other aliens?
And what does this discovery mean for us?
This is what F and here's what would happen if there's life
on Venus,
Venus might not be as alien as you think the
planet is roughly the same size as earth.
And its gravity is 91% of our planets.
We always talk about Mars being a potential home for humans,
but we shouldn't count out Venus either.
And if there is life on the planet,
could this speed up our process of making it our new home.
First let's look into why exactly scientists think there might be life on
Venus. It all has to do with phosphine.
This is a colorless, flammable and explosive gas.
That's also pretty stinky.
It smells like a mix of garlic and decaying fish.
This gas can be found on earth and it's dangerous to everything that uses
oxygen to survive.
It used as a chemical weapon during world war one and is a by-product of cooking
methods. Yeah,
this gas is not very pleasant and it can be extremely deadly,
but now astronomers have found that phosphine might
be in Venus's atmosphere
at first glance.
This might seem like a terrible thing because this gas kills anything that
breathes oxygen,
but that doesn't mean that life can't exist just because
something doesn't require oxygen doesn't mean it's completely lifeless
inside Venuses clouds of phosphene. There could be anaerobic bacteria.
These are organisms that don't require oxygen to survive.
They could be living on Venus producing this phosphine gas.
Keep in mind that all of this is not fully verified yet,
but astronomers have been keeping an eye on Venus for nearly all of 2020.
And this is what they think they've discovered.
So if this type of alien life really did exist on Venus,
what would it mean for us humans? Well,
when you first hear about alien life,
you think about Martians with big heads and us being able to shake their
hands, but that wouldn't be possible with these life forms on Venus,
as it stands right now,
we wouldn't be able to see any of the life on Venus with our naked eye.
It's all bacteria and microbes.
And with all that potential phosphene on the planet,
it makes visiting Venus more dangerous for humans than ever.
So will we be meeting this life form anytime soon?
Probably not.
Is this discovery still incredibly exciting? Absolutely.
And sure. It's discouraging that we haven't found Martians yet,
but try not to be too disappointed when discovering potential
alien life,
we should remember to expand our ideas about what exactly these
alien life forms could be.
They don't necessarily have to be something with two or four legs that humans
are able to interact with the possibilities for potential alien life
are endless things we can't even imagine yet.
And who knows what this current life form could turn into. It may start small,
but in millions of years,
we might see Venus bloom into a planet full of organic life
and life on Venus might not be limited to organisms living in phosphine
gas.
Either experts think that due to all the extreme climates on the planet,
life could form almost anywhere.
And that goes for the rest of the solar system too,
with scientists discovering potential life on Venus,
who knows what else is out there?
Researchers will just have to keep searching to find out.
Speaking of researchers,
one of the lead scientists who made this exciting venous discovery is on this.
Week's what if discussed?
We sit down with Dr. Sarah Seager to talk about how she found this potential
life on Venus and what exactly it means for other life in the solar
system. Check it out.